عرض مذهل في السماء التقطت العديد من
التلسكوبات ما قد يكون أحد
أكثر الانفجارات سطوعًا التي لوحظت على الإطلاق
في الفضاء ، ويُعتقد أن الآية ناتجة
عن نجم هائل انهار في
سوبر نوفا ، مراسلة قناة CNN الفضائية
كريستين فيشر هنا مع التفاصيل ،
لذا فإن كريس و  أحب النظر إليها على أنها
مجرد قطعة فنية ، من الواضح أن هناك
الكثير من العلم وراءها ، فما
حدث وما يجعل هذا نادرًا
جدًا أن نكون صادقين هو حجم
هذا الانفجار وسطوعه الذي
يجعله نادرًا جدًا ، أعني أن العلماء يعتقدون
أن  هذا هو ألمع
انفجار لأشعة غاما سيشاهدونه
لعقود ، وما تراه
هناك هو في الواقع صورة بالأشعة السينية التقطت
بواسطة تلسكوب سويفت هنا على الأرض
وما يعتقد العلماء أنه نشهد
انفجارًا  التي حدثت على بعد حوالي 2.4
مليار سنة ضوئية ، وبالتالي فإن
الجسيمات الموجودة في ضوء هذا الانفجار
كانت تسافر عبر الفضاء
لمليارات السنين ، ووصلت أخيرًا
إلى الأرض أو  كنا قادرين على
الكشف عن طريق التلسكوبات هنا على الأرض
الأسبوع الماضي أو نحو ذلك في 9 أكتوبر ، ولذا فإن
ما يعتقد العلماء أنه حدث هو أنه
كان هناك نجم هائل
أكبر بكثير في بعض الأحيان يعتقدون
أن حجمه أكبر بكثير من 30 إلى 40 مرة من
حجم شمسنا و  انهار إلى
مستعر أعظم وخلق ثقبًا أسود
وهذه الثقوب السوداء حديثة الولادة
معروفة حقًا بتكوين هذه الجسيمات التي
تتنقل عبر الفضاء بسرعات تعرفها
أحيانًا أسرع من سرعة الضوء
كما أنها تنتج كميات كبيرة من
الأشعة السينية وأشعة جاما
بالإضافة إلى قدرة التلسكوبات على
التقاطها ،
فقط تعرف أن هذا مجرد مشهد
لهذا الانفجار من الفضاء ، كانوا أيضًا
قادرين على اكتشاف انفجارات الأشعة السينية وأشعة غاما ،
لذلك ما تراه هناك
هذا اللون الأصفر  أه دائرة فيونا هذا هو
الانفجار الفعلي هناك وهذا ما تمكن
التلسكوب الموجود على الأرض من
التقاطه وإعطائك فكرة عن مدى
ضخامة وسطوع أحد فرق البحث
يسمونه الآن أه القارب
الذي تعرف أنك سمعت عن الماعز
الأعظم في كل الأوقات ويطلقون
عليه الآن اسم القارب الأكثر لمعانًا في كل
العصور ولذا يعتقدون أن هذا قد يكون
أكبر وألمع انفجار لأشعة جاما
التي سنراها على
الأرض لعدة عقود